ARUN NAGARAJAN: --episode of
Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagarajan, and
we're actually coming live
from our London studios.
I'm usually in the Google Apps
Developer Relations Team, and
you probably have seen me from
the New York office and
Mountain View office before, but
it's my very first trip to
London and today's episode is
extra special because we have
an engineer from our team.
NICK JOHNSON: Hi.
I'm Nick Johnson from
the AdSense API Team
right here in London.
The AdSense API gives you
programmatic access to your
AdSense account.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
And it's actually, I should say,
sunny in London, which I
was surprised by.
I think I packed a lot of
sweaters and jackets that I
don't need, which is good.
NICK JOHNSON: I think we were
all surprised by that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you said you
were at a ski trip where
it was warmer--
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah, it was
warmer in the ski resort than
it was in London.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
awesome.
I'm glad to be here.
Today's episode's extra special
because what we do is
a series called Script It!,
which basically is all about
using Apps Script in
interesting, innovative ways
where you can build something
that you may not normally
think about with Apps Script.
So Apps Script is all about
taking Google Apps and doing
more with it, whether it's
extending the UI to show a
menu within Spreadsheets,
or taking the data from
Spreadsheets and exposing that
to another service, into
Drive, for instance, or
automating things so every
half hour, check for an email
from a particular person and
then alert me if something
interesting happens.
So integrate, extend, and
automate are the three things
about Apps Script that are quite
common in different apps
that we've seen, workflow
apps and so on.
But AdSense, which I'm not
super familiar with--
I kind of caught up with Nick
earlier to figure out what the
product is about what the API
is for, and if you can walk
through what the product is for
and what the API is all
about, that would
be really good.
NICK JOHNSON: OK.
Well, AdSense is a monetization
solution, lets
you monetize your website
based on ads.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
NICK JOHNSON: Very simple,
very straightforward.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So if I'm a blog
publisher, I'd want to
drop in AdSense into
my page if I'm--
NICK JOHNSON: If you're a small
blog publisher, as I
myself am, you can just very
easily fire up an AdSense
account, stick a small ad on
your blog, and receive a check
in the post to a
certain extent.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Can't complain.
And then what's the
API all about?
Why is there an API?
And can you show a little
bit about the API?
NICK JOHNSON: Well, yeah.
Basically, there are essentially
two main use cases
we think of for the API.
The first is if you're a larger
organization which is
using AdSense and you have
a need to use your own
dashboards, your own systems,
you don't want to use the
AdSense front end as it is.
You can use the API to pull
in your reporting
and inventory data.
Secondly, you might be a
developer who is building a
mobile app or a desktop
app, a web app.
So if you look in the IOS or
Google Play Stores, you'll see
plenty of examples
of those as well.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
So a lot of folks are already
using the API heavily.
Excellent.
And so can you show
where someone can
learn more about AdSense?
NICK JOHNSON: Yep.
Well, if you look on the Google
Developers page here,
you can find the AdSense
Services
from within Apps Script.
So as you see, we have a fairly
comprehensive set of
documentation for that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And to be clear,
AdSense has two APIs.
The API that we expose from
Apps Script is the AdSense
Management API, correct?
NICK JOHNSON: Yes,
that's correct.
We also have a second product,
the AdSense Host API, but
that's not really
relevant here.
It's a different product
entirely.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
And can you point out
the page again?
It's under
apps-script/serviceAdSense,
that's right?
NICK JOHNSON: AdSense,
that's correct.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Under
developers.google.com.
So it's pretty easy to find.
So can you show a little
bit about the code
and what can be done?
NICK JOHNSON: OK.
Well, what we have here is a
fairly simple example we put
together using Apps Script.
So if I just go over to an
example AdSense account, I
have a spreadsheet here, an
ordinary spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's take
a look at the screen.
NICK JOHNSON: I'll just roll
up my sleeves, and you'll
notice, those of you who are
familiar with Google Docs
Spreadsheet, there's an extra
menu on the right here which
we've added using Apps Script.
So I have New Report, Refresh
Report, which I'll come to
shortly, and then a couple of
preset reports from the
AdSense front end.
So if I hit Overview Last Month,
it'll think about it
for a moment, fill in some
columns, start date.
So what I have here is I've
pulled up a very basic report
of your account for the
previous month.
So you have dates, number
of ad requests,
coverage, which is--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And it knew
which account to dial into
because who you were logged
in in the spreadsheet.
NICK JOHNSON: Yes, it uses the
account you're logged into as
the spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Very cool.
So you didn't have to
reauthenticate or anything.
NICK JOHNSON: No, none
of that at all.
And if you didn't want to use
one of the presets, I can hit
New Reports, and I've built a
very basic kind of UI which
lets you assemble it.
But if I just move away from
that for a moment.
This is one of the cool things
which you're able to do with
Apps Script.
If I realize actually,
this wasn't the
data I wanted at all.
I didn't want last month.
I wanted the last two months.
So remembering how American
dates work, if I change that
to a two and then I just come
up here and refresh this
report, give it a moment to
think, and just like that,
there's no further data.
So that wasn't the
best example.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So
all the money was
made in the last month.
NICK JOHNSON: All the
money was made in
the last month here.
So let me try something
else instead.
Let's decide instead, let's say
I'm not interested in ad
requests at all, but I am
interested in how much money
was made by each of the
different ad clients or
products which we used here.
So if I just change this to Ad
Client ID, hit Enter, and
refresh the report, I now
have the same data but--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
really cool.
So what you've been able to do
there is the header actually
corresponds to fields
in the API?
Is that correct technically
speaking?
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But as far as
the user is concerned, they're
just deciding which
column to see.
NICK JOHNSON: Exactly, it's
just a spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
NICK JOHNSON: And I can
actually, we added as well
another neat little thing we
were able to do is I've got a
Help thing here, which we
figured, why not just use a
spreadsheet?
So we have a list of all the
different dimensions and
metrics which you can use.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's
a nice trick.
So is that a hidden sheet,
or is that something that
automatically populates?
NICK JOHNSON: No, this is
generated on the fly by the
Apps Script itself.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Very cool.
Very cool.
So how does this magic work?
So what did you have to do to
pull this all together?
Can you reveal your tricks?
NICK JOHNSON: Well, that's a
very good question and I'm
glad you asked it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Wasn't
set up at all.
NICK JOHNSON: Actually, why
don't I just take a step back
and say Tools, Script
Editor here.
So if I move over to that window
now, I've blown the
text up nice and big
so you can see it.
First of all, this gives away
some of the magic right away.
On the left hand side, you
will see the names of
dimensions and metrics here.
And on the right hand side,
I've put more friendly,
English versions of them,
which is what's used to
generate the Help page.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
That makes sense.
So you have a map of what makes
sense to the user versus
what the API uses.
NICK JOHNSON: Precisely.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
OK, cool.
NICK JOHNSON: And then I
have them ordered as
well, just to simplify.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: What that's
also good for is you could
localize it, potentially.
So you could potentially have
a Spanish version or French
version, where they may type in
what makes sense to them in
that locale.
If that matches up to that same
tag, then you will get
the right data.
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
That would work to some extent,
although some of the
slightly cheesier hacks I've
used here wouldn't work in
that case, but we'll come
to those later.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But
that's a potential
exercise for the viewer.
NICK JOHNSON: And then just
here, these are the lists of
dimensions and metrics which
are used for the Overview
Reports which you
saw on the menu.
And then second, I used one of
the special functions that's
available in Apps
Script on open.
So essentially, this method runs
immediately as soon as
you open the spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's a trigger in Apps
Script parlance.
NICK JOHNSON: So this creates
the magical AdSense menu.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And I also see that you are
programmatically building that
array instead of populating
it in a big chunk.
It's much easier to
read this way.
Everybody has a different way
to do that menu population,
and it's interesting to see
how you've done it.
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah.
For me, this corresponds more
closely to what actually pops
up, but I guess that would be
different for everyone.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you're also
using separators to clean
up your UI a little bit.
I think that's a trick that a
lot of folks may not know of.
But if you pass in Null into a
menu object instead of a Name
and Function Name property,
you'll actually get a nice
clean separator.
And I've seen some people
actually use hyphens and
dashes to clean up menus,
but we actually have a
nice trick for that.
NICK JOHNSON: I'll go back
to the script now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Now so far,
you've shown the API
parameters to English literal
mapping and how the
menus are set up.
Where is some of the
magic happening?
NICK JOHNSON: Just a little
bit more magic, Uninstall,
which just triggers the menu to
appear should you install--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: From
the Gallery, yeah.
NICK JOHNSON: From
the Gallery.
And then we have a whole bunch
of utility methods which
create dates.
And then these are the methods
which actually create the
default reports.
A couple of little total and
average things there.
And actually, I'm going to do
this sort of upside down.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: A lot
of code in there.
NICK JOHNSON: It's
a big script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Magic
is not easy.
NICK JOHNSON: Actually, I'll
show you there right at the
bottom, we have the Get
Help method here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's a nice
trick as well for our viewers
that may want to do something
that's spreadsheet-based, and
if you're just distributing
all the content through a
script, it's a great way,
I think, to show Help.
NICK JOHNSON: So this literally
just creates a new
spreadsheet, uses the list which
you saw and map you saw
right at the top, and populates
the spreadsheet
using those.
There's nothing super clever
happening there.
And then the actual magic, as
such, the bit that my manager
would describe sneeringly as
magic, the bit that pulls out
the column names is here,
and it's fairly simple.
We just iterate along the top
row of the spreadsheet using
the data range and then look for
the right edge, which I'll
come back to.
And then every value it finds,
it replaces spaces with
underscores and converts it to
uppercase, which lets you
choose your own capitalization
as long as it's in about the
right form for the--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So that
essentially normalizes the
headers into something
that's more systemic.
NICK JOHNSON: And then we
attempt to find an entry in
either the list of metrics or
dimensions up at the top, and
if we find one, then we turn
that into a request, which is
made to the API.
And if we don't, we do something
else, which I'll
just demonstrate.
So if I type something which is
not a dimension or metric
here and then refresh the
report, it turns red
because that it--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Could you zoom
in a little bit, Nick?
It's actually kind
of cool, too.
So that's a nice way to not
block the user, but you just
tell them that I did not
populate this column.
NICK JOHNSON: Precisely.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
That's great.
NICK JOHNSON: So I'll go
back to the code now.
And then having iterated through
those, we've already
gathered through that what the
right hand edge of the actual
column you just entered was,
so then we look along the
right edge for the words Start
Date and End Date and use the
cells to the right of those
to pull those numbers out.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And that could
have been a pop up.
In this case, it's
non-obtrusive to
have it in a cell.
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah, it was
more magic, essentially.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: How
does it know?
NICK JOHNSON: Magic Spreadsheet
was the code name
if this had one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's funny.
NICK JOHNSON: And then if
I can actually find
this in my own code.
Why don't I take advantage--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Of the
new search features.
NICK JOHNSON: --of that.
Find the wrong thing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's also harder
to navigate at that
zoom level that you have.
One of the things, as Nick is
finding that, I'll talk about
is the reason some of this
data makes sense in
spreadsheets is that
it gives you an
immediate charting interface.
So a lot of folks take this
tabular data and are able to
build line graphs and pie charts
and other scatter plots
that may make sense, based on
the data that they care for.
So it's actually interesting
that it's not just the data
you're able to acquire, but
some intelligence from
viewing that data.
You could archive it, you
could have it published
automatically to a Google site
or an internal portal.
So there's a lot of nice things
that you can do once
you get it into a spreadsheet
or hook into
it with Apps Script.
NICK JOHNSON: And the final
bit of magic happens here
where it drops the data it gets
from AdSense right back
into the report.
There's a little bit of
cleverness here and there, but
nothing really special.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
So one thing that we failed to
mention earlier was the way
you get access to the AdSense
API is by enabling external
Google APIs.
We're not actually going to show
that panel because that
contains the API key that we use
for this demo, but if you
could just quickly show where
in the menu it is.
And also, there's a really good
tutorial that we have
which walks you through a
lot of details on how do
you set this up.
In this case, it shows you how
the charts work as well.
And this actually is a different
set of code and all
about automation versus some
of the stuff that Nick is
showing here, which is about
dynamically populating a
spreadsheet with parameters that
are purely column header
based, rather than you knowing
what the API is all about and
all the details about it.
So this spreadsheet you could
put in front of a business
user that's used to various
reporting solution, doesn't
know what API stands for, and
they're able to use this.
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah, the whole
idea behind this example was
something simple that your
average, ordinary AdSense user
could very easily just sit down,
plug data into, and have
their data just pop up
in a spreadsheet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Can you pull up the tutorial
again that's there today?
Yeah, this is it.
So in this tutorial, there are
a couple of sections that are
really important.
One is the getting an API key.
So you need to go to what we
call the Developer Console.
And it's actually a really
straightforward process.
The reason we need this is to
track the utilization of the
API against your account, just
to make sure that no one
person is disproportionately
using the API and affecting
other users.
So we can't show you the console
because that reveals
our API key, so you'd want to
track your own and keep it
safe as well.
But it's actually really
straightforward.
And if you just follow the
tutorial that we have today
under our Tutorial section, that
will show you a lot of
the details on how do you
get an API key and where
do you paste it.
AdSense is one of those special
Google APIs that you
see under, I believe it's
Tools, Use Google APIs.
And you get a pop up, and you're
able to toggle on the
right APIs you care for.
Once you do that, autocomplete
will now have AdSense dot, and
then all the class names.
What is probably the most
important AdSense class that
someone needs to know
about, or method?
NICK JOHNSON: Probably--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's take a
look at the screen here again.
NICK JOHNSON: If I just flip
back to the documentation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The
documentation, that's a great
way to show that.
NICK JOHNSON: I can actually
just talk a little bit about
each of the concepts
we have here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Sure.
That will be really helpful.
NICK JOHNSON: So I
mentioned before,
Inventory and Reporting.
So we've only really talked
about Reporting here, but
something also important which
feeds into that is what we
call Ads Inventory.
So you have Ad Clients, which
are essentially the
products you use.
So if you have a blog, that's
called AdSense For Content.
You could also monetize a search
engine on your blog.
This is AdSense For Search.
There's AdSense For Mobile
Search, AdSense For Video,
AdSense For Games.
There are a bunch of these.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So no
content left behind.
NICK JOHNSON: No one.
Below each of those, you have
a set of Ad Units, which are
your actual ads.
These are the server side
association to the actual code
you put on your page.
You have Custom Channels, which
you see here, which are
essentially--
I've heard them called Tracking
Codes or Labels.
You might use these to organize
categories on your site.
So if you have a cooking
site, you might have
pizza, pasta, haggis.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And those
are all the tags?
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah.
These are custom channels.
And then lastly, you have URL
Channels, which are sort of
what they sound like.
They allow you to group your
content to different URLs.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
And this mirrors the existing
AdSense Management API.
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So if someone is
used to calling the AdSense
Management API via REST,
then this will seem
very natural to them.
NICK JOHNSON: It's almost
identical, and even more so,
it mirrors the terminology
from the
AdSense front end itself.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
NICK JOHNSON: So if you're an
AdSense publisher and you use
the front end, all these
terms should be
reasonably familiar to you.
And if you're a developer, they
should be familiar to
your users.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
NICK JOHNSON: And then lastly,
you have the Reports
Collection, which the Reports
Collection here and the
Reports Generate Response.
These are almost certainly the
most important and useful
classes and objects
which are in this.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
NICK JOHNSON: So if I go to the
Reports Collection, you'll
see the Reports Generate Method,
the only method.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: With really
good samples, too, I see.
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
Silvano did a fantastic job
building the tutorials and
samples for these.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Who's now
at the Google+ Team.
That's great.
So the reason that I wanted to
point this out is that this
API, if you're using AdSense
today using our REST APIs and
you're running it on App Engine
or your own local
desktop, Apps Script provides
a cloud-based environment
where you're able to plug in
pure JavaScript and then
automate that reporting
aspect of it.
And it's easy to get started.
Go to script.google.com, and
anyone with a Gmail account or
Google Apps For Business account
can start this, and
you're able to very
easily get going.
So definitely check out the
documentation, a lot of good
details in there.
Check out the tutorial that
Silvano wrote that talks about
the automation aspect
of AdSense.
And then we hope soon to share
this magic spreadsheet and all
the code associated with it
so that it acts as a great
resource for the community
out there.
Anything that we missed?
I think we covered all the
things that we wanted to.
NICK JOHNSON: Yeah, I think we
covered all the major points.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, so we're
super excited to have Nick and
show all the cool stuff that
he's built, this magic.
And we hope to share the code
with you very soon, as soon as
that's ready and fit for
sharing, and as soon as
there's a way to publish
it as well.
And we're really excited to
see what the community can
build with it.
I think this, along with a lot
of different analytics, APIs
that we have, you can actually
take spreadsheets and act as
both input and output mechanism
for analytics
information.
Because it's so data rich and
information heavy that showing
it as a chart or showing it as
some other alerting based
interface, I think is
really valuable.
So thank you very much for
joining, and thank you Nick
for joining us as well.
NICK JOHNSON: Thank you very
much for having me.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yep,
absolutely See you.